one more time for Eliza Skinner
everybody Eliza antastic I love the line
about a bird eyes marble into a butthole
oh yeah
do you remember sometimes I remember
where I was when a line like that hits
me like I've been working the bird chunk
and then you're like driving and you're
like wheat him well I was trying to
explain why I don't like birds yeah and
it is uh it's like it's like that weird
fleshy circle around the eyes yeah like
well it looks like a flock it's good and
I said that conversationally and the
people around me thought I was a
horrible monster but I was like good for
stage I don't want to just put your
action knife Red Nose is very very
that's and people invite that into their
home's yeah that's crazy can I do that
in that bit no I don't we do a show
every day I'd love to do the bird
monologue and it doesn't seems proven Oh
there'd be great that'd be great no uh
well I don't like to ask normal
questions let's do some weird questions
we both used to live in New York what's
the grossest thing you ever saw uh
stranger Street sex strangers stranger
you knew they didn't know each other
they did not seem to have the respect
that he took acquaintances that no
chemistry
no he's kissing her ear dope none of
that there was a laugh from behind me
that was like knowing is he here I
remember yeah and then it rained and
washed us off yeah uh what's your
favorite x-men uh
I mean Kitty Pryde probably okay I've
done I've done Kitty Pryde voice for
cartoons before yeah yeah can you do it
well it's this little bit I'm kind of
losing my voice so at this point in the
day I always get back to the office new
Krusty I just go uh hey Bart what I got
that's all I got yeah when I yawn I
think I sound like Snoopy or um yeah
like Snoopy Snoopy as I said
that's the most rewarding type of
compression where you're like Snoopy
doesn't make there it is Eliza Skinner
everybody